attirer les visiteurs une première étape
pour les membres du Lion's Club ce
mercredi 6 septembre ils étaient une
dizaine à se relayer le but distribuer
des flyers et collecter des dons à
destination des enfants démunis en
Île-de-France au Sénégal et en Ukraine
nous avons besoin d'un peu près tout ce
qui se fait en fournitures scolaire de
du taille-crayon
jusqu'au cartable en passant par les
cahiers les gommes les stylos les
feutres une première pour le centre
commercial de Westfield à Vélizy 2 qui
accueille l'événement on a énormément de
partenariats avec des associations
locales avec lesquelles nous travaillons
de façon à pouvoir développer un petit
peu l'état d'esprit du vivre ensemble le
vivre ensemble un état d'esprit partagé
par les consommateurs soucieux de rendre
service il y a tellement de personnes
qui sont malheureux que bon
nous on peut faire quelque chose donc
pourquoi pas je vais aller chercher des
fournitures scolaires et puis
ça fera ça apprendra un enfant à avancer
et
à apprendre c'est bien
l'association a collecté plus de 4000
euros de fournitures scolaires
[Musique]